FIRST IN THE LAST 2 MINUTES,
HALLIBURTON WILL TAKE IT OUT.
INDIANA DOES HAVE A TIMEOUT.
ONE, 15, ONE, 13 LAKERS
PACERS. GET IT IN TURNER FOR
THE LEAD SHORT. HALLIBURTON,
HALLIBURTON. THIS IS TO WIN
THE GAME. THESE ARE THE KIND
OF GAMES WHERE HE LOOKED BACK
ON IT. YOU JUST. JUST DREAD
LOOKING AT THE TATE. YOU HAD
THE GAME UNDER CONTROL AND
THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU
RELAX. AND AS A RESULT. YOU
LOSE AT THE BUZZER A 3
POINTER. ANDREW HARD. THE
LAKERS FORCED THE FIRST MISS
BUT COULD NOT GET THE REBOUND.
AND AS A RESULT, YOU'RE OUT OF
POSITION DEFENSIVELY. BALL
TIPPED AROUND LOOK, NOBODY'S
MATCH IT UP. THERE'S PEOPLE
THERE THAT YOU'VE GOT TO MATCH
UP. THE PEOPLE. GIVE CREDIT TO
HALLIBURTON FOUND HIM. THAT
WAS THE 4TH MADE 3, BUY HARD.
TONIGHT. AND FOR HALLIBURTON,
HIS 14TH ASSIST AND A
HEARTBREAKER FOR THE LAKERS.
AND WHAT A GRITTY WIN OVER
INDIANA. THIS THIS IS JUST
GOING TO BE A REAL DIFFICULT
PEEL FOR THE LAKERS YEAH, THEY
WERE VERY DIFFICULT. THEY WERE
UP BY 7 POINTS. THEY HAVING A
GOOD TIME. GOT TO PLAY WITH
THE SAME KIND